[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قبل ساعات من الان نجحت المهمه
التاريخيه السعوديه نحو الفضاء بابنائها
الرواد المهمه الاستكشافيه استكشاف الكون
ومعرفه اسراره علميا
انطلقت مشاهدينا من مركز كندي الفضائي في
فلوريدا وحملت معها ريان برناوي وعلي
القرني الى التاريخ كونهما اول اذا فضاء
سعوديين يخوضان التجربه الفريده برفقه
ورائد الاعمال الامريكيه جون شوب التعاون
بين الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء ووكاله ناسا
وشركه
اثمر عن الوصول الى هذه الرحله التاريخيه
لينطلق صاروخ
حاملا مركبه دراغون 2 باتجاه محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
يلا يلا اوكي
اوكي تفضل رئيس الهيئه السعوديه مشاهدينا
للفضاء الدكتور محمد التميمي في تصريحات
للعربيه ومن مكان الانطلاق قال ان مملكه
اصبحت الاولى عربيا بارسالها ثلاثه رواد
فضاء الى محطه الفضاء الدولية التميمي
اضافه ان رائد الفضاء السعوديين سينفذان
14 تجربه علميه وطبيبيه ابرزها رفع كفاءه
علاج السرطان والامراض المزمنه بالاضافه
الى تجربه رفع كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار التي
ستنفذ للمره الاولى على محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
نهنئ القياده ونبارك لهم نجاح الاطلاق
وارسال اول رائده فضاء سعوديه وعربيه
ومسلمه واول رائد فضاء سعودي الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه نبارك للوطن بكل فخر
واعتزاز هذا الانجاز التاريخي في خدمه
الوطن والعلم والانسانيه وصدقا لم يكن هذا
الانجاز ليتحقق لول الدعم الكبير والتمكين
من سمو سيدي ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للفضاء قبل عده اسابيع التقى برواد الفضاء
واكرمهم بكلمات ملهمه ومحفزه هي وقود
الحماس والشغف لدى رواد الفضاء لما اطلعوا
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المهمه هي
احدى برامج
رواد الفضاء في تبع الخطه السنويه تبع
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للفضاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في رصيد المملكه
ثلاث رواد الفضاء فيصير ترتيبنا في على
مستوى الدول مجموعه العشرين التاسع ونحن
الاول على مستوى المنطقه في عهد الفضاء
الذين صعدوا الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه رواد
الفرج يقوم بعده تجارب علميه عددها 14
تجربه علميه وطبيبيه من اهمها احدى تجارب
برفع الكفاءه علاج السرطان والامراض
المزمنه بالشراكه مع مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي والثاني تجربه جدا مهمه ولاول مره
تقام على محطه الفضاء الدوليه وهي لرفع
كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار ولها فائده الفائده
الاولى لرفع تقنيات الاستمطار على الارض
ومعالجه التحديات البيعه على الارض
والثانيه ايضا لدراسه امكانيه الاستمرار
على الكواكب الاخرى وهذه التجربه والشراكه
مع جامعه الملك فهد والبترول والمعادن
اكس
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي اللي كان المفترض يكون ويانا صوت
وصوره ولكن للاسف يعني بسبب حادث خطاك
السوء يا عبد الرحمن عبدالله على السلامه
حدث مروري بسيط منعني من الوصول الى معرض
الفضاء
المقام لكن عادل هذا الحدث تاريخي المهم
الذي يعني شاهده جميع العالم وعلى راسهم
السعوديون
كان ملفت للنظر متوقع راويه وعادل انه
الالتحام مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه
ووصول رواد رائدي الفضاء السعوديين الى
الى المحطه
الدوليه متوقعه الساعه الرابعه والنصف
مساء بتوقيت السعوديه ربما يتاخر نصف ساعه
او يزيد
وفتح باب الكبسوله
تحضيرا لنزول الرواد الى المحطه سيكون
الساعه السادسه والربع بتوقيت السعوديه
مساء طبعا الاحتفاليه لاستقبال الرواد في
المحطه ربما يكون الساعه
6:45 مساء بتوقيت
طبعا هيئه الفضاء تجهيزا لهذا الحدث المهم
اقامه معرضا في ثلاث مدن سعوديه
ابراز هذه الرحله
وترك تفاصيلها للجمهور بشكل عام في الرياض
وفي جده وفي الظهران هذه المعارض تفتح
يوميا من التاسعه صباحا وحتى الثاني عشره
مساء ومن اربعه مساء حتى عشره مساء هذه
المعارض راويه هدفها انه تجعل الناس تشاهد
محاكاه الطيران في الفضاء راح نكون معك
طبعا في الايام القادمه لحتى يعني يمكن
تنقلنا صوره اكثر تفصيلا عن هذه المعارض
بدي اقول لك بدي اشكرك يعني عبد الرحمن
واقول لك الحمد لله على سلامتك بس اكيد
انت بما انك سعودي يعني احنا كلنا كعرب
وانتم ايضا كمان كسعوديين فخورين جدا في
هذا
اليوم شكرا لك يا عبد الرحمن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات